You probably already know that computers
represent numbers in binary, or
base two internally.
The value of computer memory is
literally represented as a sequence of 1
and 0 bits.
But when you're writing code in
a language like Python or JavaScript,
you don't normally see the binary.
Numeric values are normally
displayed in decimal, and
other values such as strings or
Booleans hide the actual binary
representation away from
the programmer and the user.
The letter a can be encoded as 01100001.
But you don't need to know
that to print the word apple.
The binary representation is
available to you when you need it.
But IP addresses are one of those places
that the binary becomes a little bit
more obvious.
All of the information that's
transmitted over a network link travels
in the form of a long stream of bits.
It's divided up into
messages called packets, and
each packet carries with it the IP
addresses of the sender and
the recipient, and
these are each a binary number.
An IP address is a 32-bit value or
4 bytes.
Networking people will often said that
it's four octets instead of bytes
because some old computers
use different sizes of bytes.
An octet is specifically eight bits.
This binary or this hexadecimal
representation make up the same IP
address that in decimal
we write as 241.10.27.53.
Writing the bytes or
octets separated with dots makes them
a lot easier to read, than if we
ran them together in plain decimal.
Besides IP addresses, we'll see several
other binary values that occur in
packets which have different lengths and
bits.
In networking, the width of a field
tells how many bits are in that field.
We'll say, for instance,
that an IPv4 address has a bit
width of 32 or it's 32-bits wide.
Meaning 32 bits are used
to represent that value.